So to wrap up this portion of the hands-on lab,
there's a couple more things that we want to cover.
Now the first is, if you recall, when we created our SKM bot
and added it to our sequence, we
had converted it to a replaceable.
The question is, well, how do we actually replace that
at runtime?
So what I'm going to do is actually just unlock
my viewport here.
So I've got a free camera.
And I'm going to just find some place kind
of hidden in the world.
We'll just go over to this location here.
And I'm going to go to my content browser.
And I'm going to go down to our bots.
And it should be our mesh.
And I'm looking for this SKM bot runtime.
We'll go ahead and just drag him into the level.
Now, real quick note here, SKM bot runtime
is really no different from our SKM bot in the sense
that the only thing that's changed is the coloration.
With spawnables, you will more than likely
want to target, say, for example, a character blueprint that
will be whatever the player is using at runtime,
as opposed to what we're doing here with just adding
an actor to the level.
Now, one other caveat here is in subsequent versions
of the engine, this may change
to where you don't have to add the actor to the level.
You may be able to target from the content browser
or load something.
But for the purposes of this class,
we're just going to drag it in here
so we can easily target the actor.
All right, let's go back to our little platform
here where we have our animation,
back to our sequence.
So here's our SKM bot.
Now, to do the replacement, we actually
need to drag the sequence into our level.
So go back to our content browser drawer
here in our sequence example folder.
And in this case, the one I'm working with
is my sequence 105 example.
I'm just going to drag this in here
because this is the location, the position,
and this is where we'll do it.
So in the Sequencer Detail panel, so again,
if you don't have that, just click the actor.
We're going to scroll down, and what we're looking for
is our binding overrides.
So I'm going to click a little plus button here to add it.
We'll expand this out.
Object binding LD, you'll see, is an unresolved binding.
So if we click that, you'll notice
that we have the two actors from within our sequence.
So there's our cinema camera actor and our SKM bot.
This is going to be the actor that we
are replacing at runtime.
Of course, we want our SKM bot.
And then the bound actor is going
to be that new skeletal mesh that we added.
So we could click this down from here and try to find it.
Or if we fly back, what I can do
is just kind of keep this in viewport,
click the little eyedropper, click our little bot runtime,
and then that should be good to go.
All right.
So now, if we go over to our sequence,
now again, if I preview this and hit play,
you notice that the actor is still the same.
And that's because we're viewing the preview.
If I go back, and let's go ahead and just simulate this,
which should put it in runtime.
There we go.
You can see the game is moving.
I'm just going to press G for game mode.
And you can already see it off screen here.
But now if I hit play, because again, we
are running in real time, that now the character has
been switched with that mesh.
All right, hopefully that makes sense.
Now, one thing to note here, let's
go ahead and stop the simulation.
One thing to note here is that if you
try to have multiple actors, so multiple of these SKM bots,
and you are swapping them with the same swapped mesh,
just note that right now in, I believe we're in 5.5.3,
there's a limitation that it won't actually swap it.
So you can only have one actor that
is referenced to another actor.
There are many pros and cons to that.
But for now, just know that for our final shot,
so if I go back to our 905 sequence final,
you notice in the sequence itself that we only
have the one character.
But of course, on the actual sequence itself,
we're swapping it with an additional mesh.
So hopefully that makes sense.
OK, let's go ahead and go back to our 105 sequence.
And we're going to run over just a couple other important
things to keep in mind here for organization.
All right, so within my sequence itself,
now for this hands-on lab, we're
actually building all three of our shots
in a single sequence.
You can choose to do that.
You can choose to set them up as multiples.
We're keeping it simple for the purposes of this class.
So we'll have them together.
So another way that we can say organize,
I'm going to select my SKM bot, right click.
And then what I want to do is create.
Now, I could do add a group or a different tag
if you want to stay organized.
Great way to do that.
Or I can just right click in the empty space, add folder,
and I'll just call this characters,
something like that.
Drag our SKM bot up to here.
And then maybe I want to create another folder.
So right clicking and call this cinema or something
for cameras and drag my camera in there.
And you see that, of course, we can move these
and organize them, nest them together.
Another thing just for easily recognizability
is I can right click on the folder and do set color.
So maybe I want to change my character to something
like pink.
Maybe my camera, I want to do something like yellow.
Of course, now I can roll these up and you see I can stay a little more
organized.
One other thing to keep in mind here, again,
for the purposes of this class, we
are creating all three of our shots in a single sequence.
But you may be working in an environment
where you have multiple different departments working
on a shot at the same time.
So for example, you may have an effects department,
you may have an animation department,
you may have an environment department.
One thing that really helps to keep your files organized,
as well as the ability to concurrently work
on a single sequence, is using,
so I'll right click on here, a sub sequence track.
All this is is you're just adding another sequence
to your sequence nested under here, which again could
be something just easily named as like characters,
environment, et cetera.
We cover that in the intro, but just keep that in mind
when it comes to organization.
That is probably something that you definitely
want to use in production.